I'll tell you a personal story I don't
think I've told this anywhere but when
the don't tase me bro thing happened my
parents were counseling me hey don't get
expelled from the University don't go
like I could have gone on every TV show
in the world and my parents wanted me to
be low-key don't get expelled from the
University don't go to trial with these
bogus criminal trials and I I wanted to
go on every show I wanted to go on Bill
O'Reilly and confront him for being such
a war Pig I wanted to go on Jon Stewart
and say how dare you call me a douchebag
you're a sellout I wanted to do all
these things but a voice came to me was
like honor your mother and your father
they really did not want me to go high
key with it and if I did I know I would
have become an egotistical monster I
never would have become a more refined
man and so what you were saying about
the the value in uh actually believing
in Torah or like the Jewish tradition
connecting to God without that I'd be
lost and I wasn't even someone that was
so heavy believing in God it's just
something that that occurred to me